tu as presque dix jours maintenant du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ici en france à ce raid
bonsoir raphaël bonsoir à vous tous à
chaque jour ou presque son grand oral ce
mercredi c'était devant les agriculteurs
il n'en représente plus que 1 et demi
pour cent de la population active en
france mais c'est un électorat
traditionnellement courtisé six
candidats ont donc défilé aujourd'hui à
besançon congrès annuel national de la
fnsea le premier syndicat agricole
français ils ont tenté de rassurer la
profession en crise depuis des dizaines
d'années d'autant plus préoccupée
aujourd'hui par son avenir depuis la
guerre en ukraine dont les conséquences
se font durement sentir avec notamment
cette flambée des cours de certaines
matières premières dont le blé l'horeca
politique est signée florent au dos et
lucie la tour
c'est l'histoire de promesses faites au
monde agricole en grande souffrance pour
ce grand oral de la fnsea un seul
représentant de la gauche fabien roussel
amateurs assumé de bonne viande
favorables à la réintroduction de l'ours
et du loup il affiche ses hautes
ambitions un demi million d'agriculteurs
d'ici 2030 cela suppose d'installer
entre 20 à 25 mille agriculteurs
agricultrices par an c'est un effort
gigantesque quand nous nous installons
aujourd'hui que la moitié ils ont beau
être rivaux marine le pen eric zemmour
s'accorde toujours au moins sur un point
le problème c'est l'étranger les
campagnes sont aujourd'hui victimes en
grande majorité de d'une délinquance
inadmissibles qui est une délinquance
itinérante
bien souvent il faut bien le dire
d'origine étrangère on souhaite que nous
arrêtions de signer des accords de libre
échange avec le monde entier une
concurrence déloyale impossible à vivre
pour des agriculteurs depuis bien
longtemps dans le coeur de jean lassalle
lui le fils et petit-fils de berger
tessari culteurs ne chambre pas des
ennemis
c'est pas eux qui polluent c'est pas eux
qui réchauffe la planète
et au moins ils ne mentent pas comme nos
les politiques
emmanuel macron et ils viser une chose
est sûre le président candidat peut
désormais compter sur le soutien du
patron des chasseurs
tout un symbole selon l'écologiste
yannick jadot mais ce chiffre n a droit
d'avoir un avis mais vous savez qui la
table ouverte à l'elysée depuis des
années c'est choquant c'est choquant que
les lobbys et trouver une telle place
pendant le quinquennat macro
manifestement le président des chasseurs
se transforme un peu en rabatteurs de
voix là ainsi le rabatteur de voix pour
m annuels macron moi je ne sais pas ce
qu'en pensent les chasseurs est ce
qu'ils vont apprécier d'être transformé
en gibier électorale
voilà c'est tout pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve demain
et à onze jours du premier tour un petit
coup d'oeil aux derniers sondages selon
celui de l'ifop publiée cet après midi
emmanuel macron est toujours en tête
crédité de 28% des intentions de vote
l'écart se resserre encore avec marine
le pen qui est à 21 ans et demi pourcent
jean luc mélenchon est à 15% valérie
pécresse eric zemmour à égalité avec 10
et demi pour cent et puis du côté des
petits candidats entre autres anne
hidalgo et à 2% et philippe poutou à 0
et demi pourcent philippe poutou qui dit
vouloir limiter les plus gros salaires à
5 fois le salaire minimum mais avant de
s'attaquer aux plus riches il affirme
que sa première mesure s'il est élu sera
de supprimer la fonction présidentielle
tout simplement écouté je vais pas faire
comme si je pouvais être élu un avant
déjà et après c'est vrai que la fonction
brillant ciel a en réalité ses fonctions
qu'au concert antidémocratique dans
comme ce qu'on pourrait dire qu'on soit
là la question qu'on pourrait formuler
ce serait une fois s'il y avait le
pouvoir du côté des opprimés ou s'ils
avaient le pouvoir pour la population
s'ils avaient un vrai gouvernement des
opprimés qu'est ce qu'on ferait en
première mesure
s'attaquerait à la richesse justement
c'est pour ça c'est le fond du système
qu'il faudrait sans transformer
profondément donc c'est la remise en
cause de la propriété privée des
multinationales des capitalistes
s'opposer à la fonction il faut préciser
tout de même que ce sondage quand même
l'enseignement à marine le pen est
donnée à 47 et demi pour cent au
deuxième tour elle n'a jamais été aussi
haut face à emmanuel macron 50 ennemi
s'opposer à la fonction présidentielle
est donnée à la population les moyens de
décider directement c'est aussi l'esprit
du riq le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne oui c'est l'une des
propositions phares du mouvement des
gilet jaune repris par la grande
majorité des candidats à la
présidentielle notamment ceux à gauche
de l'échiquier voici le principe une
mesure porté par un certain nombre de
citoyens pourraient être soumis au vote
de tous les français sans passer par la
case parlement en californie cette
mesure existe déjà même depuis plus d'un
siècle alors est ce que ça fonctionne
bien reportage de notre correspondant
pierrick laurent
devant cette école des parents d'élèves
manifestent contre le port du masque
obligatoire un rassemblement idéal pour
ces collecteurs de signatures comme
béquille qui défend une proposition pour
subventionner toutes les écoles
publiques comme privées
ça demande beaucoup de temps on récolte
littéralement une signature à la fois on
va aussi dans des églises n'importe quel
endroit où ni un trottoir où il est
autorisé de se rassembler
objectif soumettre cette proposition au
vote des californiens en novembre
prochain pour cela la pétition doit
recueillir près d'un million de
signatures linda n'a pas hésité à
ajouter son nom à la voile en général je
suis les propositions avec lesquels je
suis d'accord mais quand c'est bien
argumenté je peux aussi signé une
proposition juste pour que le débat ait
lieu notre système permet de lancer des
discussions
si les français adopté le même système
voilà à quoi ressemblerait leur bulletin
de vote une série de référendums mais
qui sont en fait ici rarement vraiment
d'initiative citoyenne car la seule
proposition déjà qualifié cette année
est celle défendue par l'industrie du
tabac qui remettent en cause
l'interdiction des cigarettes
aromatisées pour collecter les
signatures des professionnels ont été
payés entre 2 et 10 dollars la signature
ils ont dépensé 21 millions de dollars
pour s'assurer que leur proposition
ferait sur hilton veut que ce système
était accaparée par les grandes fortunes
cela fait des décennies que personne n'a
réussi à mettre une mesure sur un
bulletin de vote californien sans avoir
largement recours à des signatures pays
mais pour ce professeur de droit
spécialiste des référendum ce système
reste un outil efficace dans l'arsenal
démocratique
la démocratie ne fonctionne jamais
parfaitement oui vous pouvez acheter
votre place sur le bulletin de vote mais
vous n'achèterez pas le vote lui-même la
décision finale revient aux électeurs et
ils ont montré qu'ils étaient tout à
fait capable de s'opposer à l'industrie
du tabac al'inverse des philanthropes
n'hésite pas à mettre la main au
portefeuille pour des idées
progressistes
c'est ainsi par référendum que la
californie a légalisé la marijuana ou
imposé des restrictions sur les ventes
d'armes à feu
à l'un des candidats en france qui porte
cette proposition un jury qui a même
déposé une proposition de loi en ce sens
à l'automne c'est le candidat du
mouvement résistons jean lassalle oui
c'est sa deuxième tentative à la
présidentielle il s'autoproclame
candidat de la france authentique et il
aime d'ailleurs rappelé ses origines
paysannes sa spontanéité le rend
populaire il est même le candidat avec
lequel les français aimeraient le plus
partager une bière selon un récent
sondage ifop on en parle ce soir avec
karina chahbour bonsoir karina vous êtes
reporter à france 24 qui est
véritablement jean lassalle m'écouter à
66 ans donc un fils de bergers c'est un
technicien agricole de formation et qui
s'est très rapidement lancer en
politique puisque à 21 ans il est élu
maire de son village natal lourde aussi
cher dans les pyrénées atlantiques puis
il devient conseiller général député
proche du centriste françois bayrou elle
va d'ailleurs soutenir sa campagne en
2007 avant de se fâcher et de créer son
propre mouvement
résistons avec un point d'exclamation en
2013 et prend son bâton de pèlerin il
sillonne la france à pied il dit aller à
la rencontre des français il en tira
d'ailleurs un programme présidentiel de
2010 est intitulé un berger à l'elysée
alors aujourd'hui il sillonne la france
dans un autocar à son effigie et il fait
de la ruralité en tout cas il souhaite
en faire un grand thème une grande cause
nationale
s'il est élu président eh bien ils
souhaitent y concentrer il consacrer
trois milliards d'euros par an pour plus
d'accès à la santé plus d'école plus
d'accès à la 4g à la téléphonie au haut
débit mais c'est vrai que derrière cette
image il présente une autre facette
moins connue plus sombre il il à
différentes accusations d'agressions
sexuelles et puis il a multiplié ces
dernières années des déclarations à
tendance complotistes en visant les
zéniths en visant la finance sa posture
vis-à-vis de bachar el assad
a elle aussi a fait polémique il a
rencontré à deux reprises notamment en
2015 avec d'autres deux autres
parlementaires français il ya soutenu la
l'invasion la part dans l'intervention
russe aux côtés du pouvoir syrien alors
aujourd'hui il critique évidemment
l'invasion russe en ukraine mais il
souhaite que la france se désengage de
l'otan un candidat adepte des coups
d'éclat karina oui absolument l'un des
derniers en date est bien c'était le 15
mars et le 15 mars dernier il avait
menacé de renoncer à sa campagne car ils
se disent est boudé par les grands
médias évoquant alors je cite une
campagne de merde marquée par les
insultes et des injures d'une vacuité
insaisissable le 28 mars il s'est
opportunément rendu en corse en proie à
des violences il y a défendu l'autonomie
il faut dire qu'en corse et bien il
reçoit de nombreux de parrainage car
s'il est boudé par les grands médias
nationaux il n'a aucune difficulté à
recueillir les 500 fameuses signatures
et puis parmi ces grands coups d'éclat
on se souvient en pleine crise des gilet
jaune le fait qu'il est arboré
précisément un gilet fluorescent dans
l'hémicycle ce qui lui avait valu une
amende de 1500 euros et 15 ans
auparavant il avait chanté en occitan
dans le même hémicycle pour s'opposer à
la fermeture d'une gendarmerie dans sa
circonscription ils avaient eu gain de
cause et quelques années plus tard et
bien il avait observé une grève de la
faim pendant 38 jours ça dans la salle
des quatre colonnes il avait perdu 32 kg
il avait mis sa santé en danger mais là
aussi eh bien il avait obtenu la non
fermeture de la non délocalisation d'une
usine dans sa vallée alors pour pour
l'instant il tourne on l'a vu autour de
3% d'intentions de vote parmi les
français c'est un peu plus du 1,5 pour
cent qu'il avait obtenu en 2017 mais
c'est effectivement la preuve que si les
français une bonne partie des français
ont envie de partager une bière avec lui
pas sûr qu'ils aient envie de lui
confier les clés du pays merci beaucoup
qui régna pour ce portrait de jean
lassalle autres candidats qui avaient
dépassé les 4 % en 2017 mais qui
aujourd'hui donner beaucoup plus bas
dans les sondages c'est nicolas dupont
aignan oui c'est déjà la troisième fois
qu'il se présente à la présidentielle
après donc 2012 et 2017 le président de
debout la france nicolas dupont aignan
défend une ligne souverainiste et
eurosceptique soutenu aujourd'hui par
l'ancien bras droit de marine le pen
florian philippe il s'affiche avec lui
régulièrement dans les manifestations
anti vaccins son portrait est signé
florence qu'ailleurs
comme son héros le général de gaulle sur
la tombe duquel il se rend très
régulièrement nicolas dupont aignan rêve
de sauver la france de la classe
politique actuelle des mouvements
migratoires et surtout de l'europe
devant une poignée de fidèles il
réaffirme cette année encore ses
ambitions souverainiste
je consulterai les français par un
référendum sur un nouveau traité
remplaçant
l'union européenne par une nouvelle
europe des nations libres et des
coopérations concrètes à la carte
nicolas dupont aignan grandi dans
l'amour de la patrie un grand père
aviateur pendant la première guerre
mondiale un père chasseur alpin par la
seconde sa formation à lui ce sera
sciences po l'ena puis les rangs du rpr
qu'il quitte bientôt pour se rapprocher
des eurosceptiques charles pasqua et
philippe de villiers au milieu des
années 90 il devient député maire dans
l'essonne la grande banlieue devient son
fief
aujourd'hui encore il la représente à
l'assemblée nationale et défend ses
intérêts face aux décideurs de la
capitale
je dis que si on veut régler les
problèmes de paris il faut aussi régler
les problèmes de grande couronne on
n'est pas des déchets qu'on envoie
toujours plus loin
fin 2007 il crée son propre parti c'est
debout la république en 2012 il se lance
pour la première fois dans la course à
l'elysée sur le thème de la sortie de
l'euro
en 2017 il obtient près de 5% des voix
au premier tour et soutient marine le
pen au second
une alliance qui fait l'objet de vives
critiques dans la classe politique comme
dans sa circonscription mais aujourd'hui
comme hier nicolas dupont aignan
s'insurge contre emmanuel macron
le président de la république pendant
deux ans à instrumentaliser la crise du
coc vide il a manipulé l'opinion avec la
peur du coc vide et maintenant ils
manipulent l'opinion avec la peur de la
guerre
anti vaccin anti pas sanitaires il est
rejoint cette année par l'ex numéro deux
du front national florian philippot il a
également reçu le soutien de la star
brigitte bardot pour son engagement en
faveur des animaux
elle aussi elle est de toutes les
campagnes présidentielles sans jamais
évident cette présente et brigitte
bardot merci h demain pour évidemment
france 2022 l'heure du conte sera
véritablement à dix jours du premier
tour restez avec nous dans deux minutes
un nouveau journal leur paraît direct
moi-même l'univers
[Musique]